you had eight things on the checklist 1
2 3 4 5 at some point adding complexity
to the system does not help you make a
better decision at the top so you could
have a 10,000 Point checklist of what
makes a good helper it's a question of
the time that you're spending on things
is it yielding the results that you want
especially in the beginning if you
overprocess things pre-processes for too
many things especially outside of you
your like processing your time is viable
because you can easily get distracted by
all sorts of random stuff and you know
you're screwed so like where you put in
your calendar really matters and I like
processes in business too there also
comes a point where there's too many
processes and it's counterproductive so
is it actually
required Alex is an entrepreneur that
I've been mentoring for almost a decade
he runs Toronto Dan salsa which is the
largest salsa dancing school in Canada
maybe North America and he has Ambitions
to take his one location in Toronto and
take it around the world we do mentoring
sessions once a week and this week we
decided to record it so that you could
join in on the session with us if you
like it and you want to see more let me
know in the comments below all right so
we're doing this I don't even know what
we're doing this might this might become
something it might be b-roll it might be
a whole pile of nothing so don't get too
excited I would love to finish that
conversation about uh the helpers the
scoring and just just as a catch up this
all started with uh I spoke to uh Ivy
and I was struggling to help her um
figure out how to find the right helpers
for our school basically right like to
coach her on that so I wanted a
basically a simple structure I'm like if
we do this then we can find more
suitable volunteers so started with that
and created a rating system so we just
started with what makes a good helper so
we did this and I said okay on a scale
of 1 to 10 let's rate this person on
this thing we look for and this thing
and it became this whole
system what it really stems from is
obviously in part all the insec all the
mistakes I've made and you know running
a dance school at the beginning and
having everybody around who wasn't on
board for the new culture I was creating
like obviously there's lots of pain
behind it you know I'm getting emotional
talking about it but part of it is
definitely I'm the type of guy if I have
simple guidelines and
rules um it just helps me feel like I
can more consistently hit the mark don't
treat this like a show just talk to me
Jesus okay okay so
Heaven all right um actual mentoring not
not fake you know anyway okay you know
what I mean okay so just yeah I do know
what you mean I'm frustrated because um
my gut isn't always correct and it
depends heavily on whether I'm feeling
lonely or not or insecure and quite
often I I'll tend to pick people who are
sometimes The Underdogs who I can help
but in terms of the amount of help
they'll need to be successful in the
role we need it doesn't always
proportionally kind of pay off off and
so this all kind of comes from if I have
a Playbook that I can give someone you
know how many woohoo do we have in a
class give or take uh how many times we
play a song you know the perfect class
experience if I can give that Playbook
on how we judge a successful helper
versus not and raise a standard I just
believe that we're going to have not
only better helpers but more
consistently hit High performing helpers
which will lead to high performing
instructors and when you give me
feedback you basically said well Alex
you just don't have enough people right
now you have only 13 people so it's like
first go get 60 and then you can be more
picky it's my insecurity man because if
I on board someone if I pull someone in
I go all in on them having to go in on
all on someone and then be later on be
like n it kind of doesn't work
out I don't want to keep going through
that and I guess part of it is just I'm
in I don't want other people not to feel
like they they don't
belong you know it
sucks and and on the other part uh I
want something that I hire someone and
train them within a week they can on
board and find the right helpers quicker
you know if I if I train an instructor
within three days they can build quickly
six volunteers they know exactly what
the parameters are you know and so our
last conversation you said to me he said
Alex you're complicating the system you
don't have enough people is it and so
it's this give and take holy cow it's
say give and take that a fire alarm
that's a fire alarm you see things are
on fire oh it stopped oh okay and
so I was going to go in the closet um
back in the closet Alex and um and so
I'm I'm frustrated with Alex not being
flexible and having rules and how hard
that can be on people as a
leader versus I want the McDonald's
formula of you do these things this is
the secret sauce and you'll have great
staff you have a great experience you
know I just kind of vomited all all over
you right there just now earlier but so
you mean that the challenge is you're
thinking at scale when the problem right
now is not
scale so you're trying to develop this
giant
process which to open up a new new
location and another new location cool
that could be valuable but it it's so
many
steps for somebody to get going now like
how are you fig out your your goal right
now is having two new people per week
right y great so how you picking those
people and ultimately is uh a gut check
and you're going to make some wrong
decisions and you're going to make
better ones with
time ultimately it's really do they add
to the student experience is this helper
this person you're bringing on are they
going to make this the customers is
happier the students happier my
frustration with what you're saying is I
know that there's a massive layer of
insecurity at me and not insecurity of
whether I picked the right people but my
need to help people has quite often had
me pick people who are fixer uppers and
they're okay with other people but like
like it's really it's like a personal
project and so what lens are you putting
it
through they need my help right and what
lens did I tell you to put it through
they will be helpful to students yeah
will it will it contribute to the
student experience
so you don't need a a eighto
checklist it's do they contribute to the
student experience and once they're in
at the end of every semester you do a
survey and it's and one of the feedback
is how are the helpers and if that
person's name is not showing up then
this person is not contributing to the
student experience so it's a good it's
not the only metric but it's a pretty
good
metric but yeah if you're looking at
people through the lens of can I help
this person
would it be fun for me to help this
person then that's not what you're
looking for this doesn't help the
business I might help Alex's soul to
know he can help
somebody so it's just one metric will
they contribute to the student
experience yes or no and I think the
danger with so that mean when we first
talked about you were talking about
because of Ivy you wanted to give this
to your instructor so that she had a
model not as much about do you have a
model that you can use the the challenge
is
adding too many layers and not trusting
her judgment then decreases her
self-confidence and what she can
do so say you pick helpers based off of
do you think they can contribute to the
student experience and I trust your
judgment and you're going to make some
mistakes it's okay nobody gets a I
haven't gotten the perfect either the
people you think will contribute to the
student exper everything here is focused
on the class experience will they help
yes or no if if you're helping them
because you think you can help them
because they're a broken bird you're
you're using a different filter it's
it's so you're right to have a filter
great but you don't need an eight-point
filter it's a onepoint filter well the
contribute to class
experience the simpler something is the
easier it is to remember and to execute
the simpler it is the easier it is to
execute so if I said you're looking at
you know why you pick a helper great uh
why did you pick this person are they
still good for us or not if you had to
you're going to you're going to have to
go to your checklist instead of being
able to
remember but you could just say do they
add to the student experience like yes
okay good keep them so my question
is how do I raise the
bar so let's say we don't have let's say
C+ instructors but A+ instructor it's
it's hard to go from C+ to a a plus but
it's easier to go from a to A+ it's like
you talking about instructors you're
talking about helpers this whole system
came up not so much even from helpers
it's for helpers and training it's that
probation period right it's like we're
testing M for seven seven weeks whatever
it is right there're seeing what it's
like and at the end we need a quick
assessment of you know this helper
should become a helper versus their
helpers and you know what I mean
yeah what was my question oh waiting
for we were instructors and you went all
the way down to helpers and training
like okay make I'm trying to I thought
there was a link to the story but there
oh sry right there is um there it is how
do I make sure that student
experience can be they're okay at the
student experience they're great at the
student experience they're amazing at
the student experience is it right now
just go get sexy uh sex go get oh my
gosh no no no yeah yeah go go go g 60
it's go get 60 go get 60 volunteers even
if they're like okay at it at the
student experience at the serving
mentality it's higher fast Fire fast
versus higher slow Fire
fast yeah or you is higher slow fire
slow higher never some fire never higher
never fire never
perfect that model hasn't been working
no exactly see any more people I mean
you need more people you have a
probation period what's like again you
you could go super detailed on
everything you could say class by class
what this person has to do to them
instru you can make or you can make a
model for them or you can make a
checklist for yourself of Class by class
what does have to do my God that' be so
that's so amazing I'm so excited about
even just paying attention to that
checklist versus what you should be
focused on in the class like you can
only put your attention on one thing at
a time and you focused on this you're
not focused on that so how well a helper
is doing in
class week by week is not the best use
of your time I
agree week by week yes and there will be
many things that they contribute that
aren't on your official checklist so
it's not even student experience is
class experience right so what's a class
experience so for example you might have
somebody who is who is really shy and
doesn't have a ton of energy but it's
still look like if you're not a kind
person you're not going to make it in
anyway you know if you're rude to people
you're mean you're not going to make it
anyway so we're already talking about
degrees but if you're just really
shy and you don't voice your opinion on
giving people feedback and you don't
tell them what to do to improve but
you're very detailed oriented and you're
you're on the attendance and you're
checking everybody off and you get all
that stuff done and you recognize little
mistakes in class class like somebody
doesn't have a partner so they jump in
they're seeing the little things that
you aren't seeing because they're very
detailed oriented but they're not the
most energetic you know happy
person are they contributing to the
class experience like yeah so keep them
but you're talking about two different
things like you're bringing on you're
bringing on people through a framework
of can I help
them so you're to that okay I need a new
framework which is right you should you
should have a better that's not a good
framework to build a
business if you're bringing employees on
it shouldn't be can I help this person
grow as the only you know they have to
be able to contribute to your
business but you're jumping to a now
complex framework and you're thinking
how do I scale to be able to have all
these locations and all these
instructors with this framework like by
the time you get there as a company the
framework's going to change and way more
important framework is going to be put
in place so you don't have to worry
about where you're at in three years or
how many locations you have you need to
get the 60 people from the 14 or
whatever you're at right
now and you need a framework but a
simple one because the framework you've
been using has been can I be a life
coach for this person as opposed to are
they a good fit for my business do they
contribute to the class
experience yes or no yes cool borderline
okay then a maybe and you're testing
them out for a semester anyway so like
when I'm
training well part part of this whole
conversation also is trust your people
to make the mistakes and and Coach them
along so you know and make judgment
calls that override their judgment and
no no trust your people you said trust
the people that make mistakes you're
already just assuming they're going to
make just all mistakes I'm trusting
their judgment call you said trust your
people that make mistakes yes okay but
they're going to make mistakes I make a
ton of mistakes yeah yeah of course you
still do but it's trust your people to
make a judgment call and inside the
Judgment call most of it will be right
like I just default the thinking most of
it will be right if you're going to if
you tell Ivy Ivy's been with you she's
she's been in she's been part of TDS for
how
long uh about a year and a half overall
like from being a student and everything
uh about a year and eight months eight
months something that yeah so almost two
years she's hung around you you've
training her multiple times per week
like you've work together she knows you
she knows the system great so would she
make the exact same choices as you no
but she's not going to go and bring on
somebody who's a a f helper unless she's
using a complete wrong framework like
you know I don't know is this guy cute
okay great he's a helper right that's
not a good
framework right so you're giving her a
framework of will this person contribute
to the class experience and then you're
saying I trust your judgment you can
either go
checklist like everything 100% checklist
which then you have to account for
everything and it takes a ton of time to
create that checklist and account for
everything and by the way you still
haven't figured it all out yourself
anyway right like you're still work in
progress you haven't gone and got your
60 or 14 so you're making a checklist on
the Fly versus what will allow you to go
faster say I trust your judgment and
then let her bring on people which will
probably be mostly good fits and there
might be a couple bad apples or wrong
choices but then you work your way
through like you're not ready to
production line this thing yet and at
some point you have to think where does
it stop being a production line it's
easier but there's a point where it
loses its um heart I guess right well
exactly I mean you're you're not in the
you're not in the Cann soup
business yeah I mean how do you have 100
locations if you don't have a can Su no
I'm touching the wrong thing you like
you the strength of PDs is the heart
so it it can't turn like if it was just
all able to be checklist and automated
great then just turn it over to Ai and
robots can come in and teach everything
and it'd be the perfect checklist every
single time how do you systemize the
heart you allow people to make judgment
calls does that take longer though no
it's f look how long it took me how's
that faster because you are given the
person in the situation the ability to
act instead of be like imagine something
happens lights go out and TDS oh where's
the checklist for this okay okay hold on
let me Let Me Wait guys let me go look
at my binder and try to find where the
checklist for this specific thing is
that's slowing it down versus I'm going
to make the best call I have and Alex
has my back what needs to be systemized
well the the process of signing up needs
to be systemized right it should be a
smooth process to sign up for a class uh
what what is taught in every class
should be systemized if somebody comes
through level one and then they do level
one with you versus level one with iy
they should learn the same thing because
if they go to level two with you coming
from Ivy that's that's a terrible like
it's say it's through the class
experience that's not going to be a
great class experience yeah right I'm
I'm I agree that was a bad experience
it's inconsistent so it can't it can't
it can't just be only do teach whatever
you want today whatever you feel like
teaching a a triple turn in level one
yeah go forward why not right
that would be that would lead to a bad
overall experience but you can't then
checklist every little
thing in the class because now you're
turning people into
robots and then it slows things
down because they're not going to
remember everything it's too much to
remember the point of making it simple
is that I can remember it the point of
looking at a helper like think about how
many things you have to an instructor
has to deal with and now you're adding
this new thing in of oh you also have to
recruit helpers to join your class so on
top of being prepared and Norm my story
and doing the the Huddle at the end and
teaching the moves and knowing the man
and the women's part and how to lead and
follow and prepping my songs and all
this stuff I also have to add this other
thing on of recruiting helpers to join
my class so now if you give me five
things or eight things that I have to
look at to recruit a helper in you're
filling my brain with too many things
and so if I'm going to now focus on this
I'm going to drop this other stuff
I mean well the answer to that isn't
necessarily you do it in class it could
be post class you look at your
attendance list right you have a
structure for that and I get your point
I get your point it's opportunity cost
so they're spending they only have so
much time to spend on TDS stuff and now
you're saying spend time on this and not
prepping for your next class reviewing
the next moves spending time with your
assistant the major things need to have
a process and that's fine it's not just
go complete gray and whatever you want
but isn't recruitment the major thing
this is my question how do I I get those
A+ instructors well for example I wasn't
an A+ instructor yeah no you wouldn't
have made it for sure I didn't even want
you to join at all because you weren't
taking feedback you would have failed
all of the things what look at your list
you would have failed a bunch of things
I mean I would have done on mine would
be like are you know can they if they're
going to grow can they take feedback
that was the biggest thing why I said
don't don't bring Alex in because he
took zero feedback you didn't want to
listen to anything in level six you well
that was wait that was that was me as a
student I think right or was it a helper
as well no I was a helper I think I
helped in your classes yeah you were a
Helper and you just didn't want you
didn't want to and I would try to give
you feedback when the when you you were
with a student and you would count I
still remember that one but I would do
it in a way that they wouldn't see ver
your worth with because they don't want
to make the helper look bad and with
their dance partner was a student where
you're supposed to know what you're
doing and you're counting off time cool
whatever you go do whatever you want to
do because like Alice should not be an
instructor so you don't need your
instructors to pick the next instructors
yet you're not you're not like you're
not even close you don't even have
helpers in training yet you're taking
you're thinking too many steps ahead
people going from student to helper in
training to helper to then assistant to
then instructor right a that's the
trajectory of a of somebody you're you
don't have enough helpers in training at
the very stop and you're worried about
getting A+
instructors like where you're at now
being able to help an inst RoR yeah that
could be a good use of time like do they
have enough raw ingredients for you to
be able to help them grow as a human but
also inside of being uh because you love
coaching so it's great it's like being
able to coach and make the lives of an
instructor better but they have to have
the wrong ingredients to be a good
instructor as well that's worth a lot of
time but doing that for every single
Helper and training doesn't make sense
so all you have to do is ask that they
contribute to the class experience but
like you look at your checklist you had
eight things on the checklist or
whatever it was four or five I think
five Max definitely more than four okay
so
let's no not more than four definitely
more than four he's going to load up
right now there's definitely more one
two three four five okay perfect four or
five five okay so so pick
one like one that I think is valuable
well I hope they're all valuable if
they're on the list I mean there's three
that I think are incredible uh two what
okay I I'll narrow down two pick one
yeah just just just serving mentality
okay perfect that's I think the most
most important one okay okay so but here
so you're you're saying now give a check
or give a letter grade for sering
mentality perfect well what's that how
how do I know you can have a checklist
for serving mentality right okay I can
have five things for serving mentality
yeah and then under those five things
could be five more things so how big is
this checklist going to
go serving mentality could be do they go
and say hi to people on their own in
class if they see somebody on a bench do
they go and say hi server mentality
perfect so that's one of the five things
for Server mentality but that could be
do they do it in every class right so
now that one has become nine things
because it's a ninee class like at some
point adding complexity to the system
does not help you make a better decision
at the top so you could have a 10,000
Point checklist of what makes a good
helper I don't think it's going to be
that much more
valuable in terms of picking than just
having one which is do the contribut
class experience and it's a heck of a
lot faster so it's a question of the
time that you're spending on things is
it yielding the results that you want
especially in the beginning if you
overprocess things create processes for
too many things especially outside of
you you're like processing your time is
viable because you can easily get
distracted by all sorts of random stuff
and you know you're screwed so like
where you put things in your calendar
really matters and I like processes in
business too but there also comes a
point point where there's too many
processes and it's
counterproductive so is it actually
required the whole thing on a newsletter
that that I sent you you wrote this
giant story about your life in the
newsletter I don't how long do you think
that took you to write it was a long
time three hours three hours okay so
then it becomes a question I could tell
you wrote it took you a long time to do
that and you probably don't spend that
much on every newsletter that you send
out no right but it it it begs the
question of like was that
worth it if it was just in a a creative
thing fun scratch the edch cool but is
it worth spending three hours on a
newsletter and maybe it's yes like maybe
it's like you know how many sales we got
from that or you know how many comments
I got back from that or you know how
many students were touched by that
message then cool keep doing it but
anything that's taking up giant chunks
of time it's a con me too it's a
constant evaluation of is this thing
still helping me or not is it is it
helping me at all or maybe it used to be
helping me and now it's not worth my
time as
much and so I need to move on so I just
saw how much time I I didn't know it was
three hours but I knew it was it wasn't
like five minutes it was a big chunk of
time that that is opportunity cost
spending three hours on that means
you're not that could have been three
hours reaching out to find helpers you
know looking at your schedule there's
probably some waste of time in there
anyway and so anything on the business
is
probably more effective than other other
activities but it's still s to to think
about is this activity helping me
achieve my goals inside the business or
just as a human and if it is awesome and
if it's not then it's worth evaluating
in my brand lick session today we had
brand litics training this morning which
is just like YouTube training one of the
people that in brand Linux and Movie
Makers and she asked hey what's
happening with the um the challenges
like you do these monthly challenges and
I'm I don't know if we should be putting
this on our channels or not and I said
well that there is no challenge for this
month we're halfway through the month
right now is this time and there's no
there hasn't been a challenge announced
and it was a test to see does anybody
notice so the challenge was you guys
they make content together right well
You' you've been there right you make
content together with three people and
then we do a live at the end right so
she said well what's the point of it and
I said well initially it was because
Movie Makers when we started were we had
a lot of beginner of people who are just
just at the early stages of making
content and they would come to the
trainings and they would ask questions
it would consume all the content but
they weren't making videos and they'd be
in for six months and they still don't
have a single video up on the channel so
just put anything up because they're
concerned about all the lighting and
camera and script and having a pimple
and whatever else like all the beginner
stuff so I started the challenge as a
way to just say just get started and
make content if you and I Al are going
to hop on a call and you're going to
talk about perseverance great like it
it's great for for both of you if none
of you are making content is It
ultimately the best content for either
of you no like does put in a video about
perseverance help Alex sell more dance
classes you know probably not right if
you're already making content it's not
it's not necessarily the best thing but
if you're at the beginning stage then
it's you got to put it out there so
Movie Makers though has shifted has
changed become a lot more expensive and
we've had the new people coming in are
already on their path of making
content so the value of having the
challenge is not there anymore and so
this month was a test to say let's let's
just not talk about it and see if
anybody
notices one person
noticed this is not
valuable we should stop doing this
because it's energy and effort every
month so it doesn't mean stop caring
about your clients it means okay so
we're spending energy here let's stop
doing that and let's let's find
something else that is now more valuable
it used to be very valuable it's not
anymore so let's shift our attention to
focus on something that can help them
more and it's for your time and then as
you scale it's team's
time so is the is is Ivy's best time
spent doing this checklist for all of
her helpers right maybe yeah maybe maybe
maybe that's like the best thing that
she could be doing but I think if you
just had one metric and instead of five
she'll make the same decision and so is
it worth spending three hours on a
newsletter maybe my response wasn't stop
doing this this is a waste of time maybe
it is worth it but that's the Judgment
called to make like if are we getting
results from the newsletter either
qualitatively or quantitatively
qualitative like people coming up and
telling you how much it means to them
quantitative is is leading the sales and
people signing up for the class and if
it's not to any of those then it's
probably not worth three hours a week
not that you're doing three hours every
week on this but this when you have
these exception cases it helps shine a
light on the situation and say is this
even worth doing it's usually when it's
like the camel the straw that broke the
camels back it's like something happens
and then it it makes you look at the
whole thing so the fact you spent three
hours on a newsletter was it our best
newsletter ever did you get a ton of
feedback on it did we get a bunch of
sales from
it was it the exact same as every other
newsletter is it even worth through new
that are period if you just sent out the
class schedule would that be enough you
know I don't know and this happens to me
too all the time there's lots of things
that we all do that we think is valuable
or we just get used to doing it because
it's part of our habits that actually
don't make a difference at all anymore
opportunity cost yeah and then you can
use that time to do something
else we're doing it for our videos
Nikolas on my team who does our video
intros and he's been spending a lot of
time editing the first minute of our
videos
to try to get as high retention possible
for the first minute and he's he's the
past week results um was lower than the
week before and what we did was we
created a checklist so we have a
checklist of like you got to hit these
things in the first minute and two weeks
ago we had just created the checklist so
he hadn't done it so he hit like half of
them last week he hit 90% of the things
on the checklist and the results went
down not a lot but it went down so okay
so we're doing a good job hitting the
checklist but we're we're picking the
wrong things for the
checklist if our results are going down
we have to come up with something
dramatically different so going to the
next week he tasked with coming with
something dramatically different and I
also said for two videos do no intros
nothing edited just go right into it
because I want a benchmark now hopefully
his videos that he's doing the new ones
crush the ones with no intros at all if
they don't they the same
then all the work that he's doing is not
helpful and so we need to we need to
rethink it either find a different way
to do one one minute intros or put him
in a completely different
position because we're spending lots of
time and energy on something that then
isn't yielding
results so it's a it's a it's a constant
evaluation this isn't just something
that you do once like it's a constant
evaluation of where you spending your
time
and is it yielding the results that
you're looking for or not if it's a
hobby if it's fun if it's personal not
everything has to have an
Roi but if it's meant to have an Roi
then it has to have an
Roi right if the newsletter is meant to
drive students then it needs to drive
students if it's for you to practice
being a creative writer don't do it
inside the business do it as its own
hobby thing just making sure the things
that are supposed to have an Roi
actually have an Roi and so how much
time do you have every day to do stuff
inside the business great is that the
best use of your time every day and for
everybody it's no for me it's no is this
the best use of my time I have no idea I
already talked to you this week why am I
talking to you
again because we're making content maybe
right this might turn into something or
this maybe never gets released who knows
it's an experiment but if we don't
release this and don't do anything with
it there's a camera on me here you know
whatever if we do something with it cool
but if we never do anything with it then
I'm not going to talk to you every week
and do
this because I'm already talking to you
on Mondays going over stuff right like
this series will die because it's not
Genera an art I I'll do something else
with this time because this is supposed
to be time to help me grow what I'm
doing it's a constant evaluation I'm
never done you're never done nobody's
ever done right Jeff Bezos made a quote
about I'm still I'm trying to optimize
what did he say I'm trying to optimize
my toothbrush
routine CU and he's making a joke but
basically saying like those 30 seconds
if you can if you can brush your teeth
30 seconds faster and still get the same
results do it 30 seconds faster part of
what I think influenc the whole thing
but not complicated system was I am
consuming a lot more um Alex
harosi about optimizing systems but and
I I I I I I see exactly what you're
talking about one is people I need to
believe in my
people that's that's that's a part of it
the other part is like investing in
complicating a system that itself
is taking more time takes away from me
getting and recruiting more and trust
your gut
Alex right now also don't think in scale
yes you have to believe in your people
and you need to make your people believe
in themselves it's that your belief in
them makes them believe in them when
they're not sure how to do it the fact
that you think they can do it makes them
think they can do it where you're often
doing the opposite and you've gotten
better at it but you've burnt out
instructors because you're too harsh and
too critical and like they feel like
they'll never get it they'll never hit
your standards for what they should
be meanwhile you were still figuring out
what the heck you were doing like the
difference of it is I if Ivy comes to
you and says I don't know how to pick
helpers I'm worried and you're like yeah
you should be like you don't have a
model you're going to suck at picking
help not that you would say that but
that's how it's easy energy the energy
the energy yeah your your your body
language your that's what you're
thinking you're thinking she's going to
suck at doing this and so that's the
energy that gets put out as opposed to
saying okay she might make some mistakes
but she's got this when you came in the
level three class and you were become an
instructor and you said Evan can you go
teach the double turn in the front of
the class I said no I'm not teaching it
you can do this I didn't know you might
fall in your face I don't
know now you didn't but what would it
have what would it have showed you if I
came in and did everything for you and
especially in front of your students
every time you had a little bit of
self-doubt that I'd never be as good as
you yeah and not even as good as me like
you may not be good
enough and then you wouldn't you
wouldn't keep going we're like no you're
you're going to do the double turn and
if you fall you fall and we'll figure it
out I didn't know how it would go it
turned out pretty well like you didn't
fall over you didn't stumble could you
have taught it better sure I mean your
first classes were a disaster but you
whatever you're thrown in there with
zero training and prep work and it was
that you were doing it so imagine if I
just destroyed you at every class and
said you suck for all these things that
was the worst class it was like and you
know I guess if we ever use this for the
people watching I told Al I gave Alex
the option to go and
teach the the day of he's got 15 minutes
as we're driving to class to say you
teach or I teach you pick and so he was
not prepared for it and so he said yes
so you did it it was it was like those
first three weeks of working with you
were the worst classes I've ever seen
from anybody in my
life but if I said that I would that
make you feel oh my God would destroy me
it's like you would it would have been
over you would have quit yeah and it was
true but I knew you could get better or
at least I hoped you could get better at
least I made you believe that you could
get better I mean it's hard to get
you can hide your body language really
well no no no but I wasn't I this is the
difference I wasn't hiding
anything I believed you would get
better it wasn't me being fake it was
equally the worst class I had ever seen
but I wasn't leaning into the fact of
how bad it was I was leaning into the
fact that you're going to get better and
leaning in the fact that I was proud
that you stepped up and even did it in
the first place like somebody who would
say yes at the last minute and do it is
going to go off and do great things
that's what I was leaning into and I
believe that that was not a lie but they
were the worst classes that I've ever
seen and whatever to be expected so what
are you leaning into you're just not
believing in your
people and so like the that's even a
bigger thing than the checklist because
what we don't want to do is bring in
things that make people lose confidence
in
themselves so you don't need you don't
need Alex's checklist I I trust
you for this now it doesn't mean again
that she's just going to go off and make
up her own level three class and do
whatever but she can do this got a lot
more self-work to do well awesome so I
mean we all do that's that's the journey
no I mean I mean the just the insecurity
of uh just being just being secure
attached you know um in my mind I always
think I I can do it better I can do it
better and that often breeds what you're
talking
about which is um people not believing
in
themselves well and you you can't do
everything
yeah and ultimately she'll find a path
that
is that is
better like she can't tell your
stories well listen um she's teaching
tonight and I get to go culture again
tonight coming in
and I'll definitely make sure that when
I come
in in my mind I believe she can get
better I'm not coming into watch
mistakes I believe she can get better
and it's I got to believe in her and
she'll come to me for feedback and I'll
give her but you can do this yeah and
belief she be again yeah yeah belief she
could be
great that's the only thing that like
the anybody who is working with you they
want that validation of
progress and so if they've made progress
amazing let them know and if they
haven't then you have to be harsh then
maybe she didn't practice maybe she
didn't go over the material maybe she
spent five minutes reviewing everything
before it doesn't mean that that's
acceptable right so you will have to
have hard conversations but it needs to
inside of the hard conversation needs to
be the belief that things can be great
otherwise why is she even there like
when I was talking to Nik about the
first minute retention it's like I think
I believe he's great and that we can
figure this out if you think about the
morale like he started off really low on
our call because he did everything we
asked him to did the whole checklist
spent tons of time we cut his workload
in half so we can spend twice as much
time on the videos that we gave him he
did everything we asked and it did had
worse results and so now he's on a call
with me like and he just the energy at
the beginning was terrible from him
right he just feels defeated doesn't
know what to
do because we interpret that as we're
not good
enough and
so it was my job to bring it back up to
say like I think you can do and I do I
believe he's great like I think he can
do great things he's done some amazing
things I think he can be great we
haven't created great things yet but I
can either pound him for all the
mistakes that he
made or believe in the greatness
so I think there always has to be some
unless you're just trying to get rid of
somebody you know even in a tough tough
conversation there has to be an
uplifting to
Greatness they should be leaving you
feeling okay I I didn't do my work I
didn't do my job if they didn't right
like only I only spent five minutes
prepping but if Alex thinks I can be
great I think I can be
great as opposed to just feeling like a
piece of crap leaving and not that she
is and not that everybody is all the
time but yeah so it's not about hiding
your feelings it's
about choosing how to feel because I
suck at hiding feelings
too yeah no I mean I suck at acting and
faking and I hate it but it's choosing
what you're going to focus
on what's my work around right now um is
it believing that I can get them there
before I can believe more that they can
get
there cuz I know I I I see what the
obstacle is right now I'm concerned I
not I might not be able to cross that
bridge because in my mind everybody
around me I'm like me I don't think it
can to be about you it's got to be about
them like you're going to help them sure
but that they have the raw ingredients
to be great at the thing that you're
ultimately asking them to
do like if they don't have the raw
ingredients to be great at
something
pick the wrong person yeah it's like
what are they doing there they need
molding they need support they need
encouragement they need training they
need mentoring they need all of all the
stuff but if you don't feel they have
the wrong ingredients and and you're a
terrible
actor what are we
doing yeah all right thank you thank you
for this um I'm going to do better with
her and also with my assistance I'm I'm
I'm getting emotional and I'm because
I'm feeling so much embarrassment you
know um about
they don't deserve to feel like that um
that they're not uh enough because of my
own um insecurities you know yeah yeah
you don't need to beat yourself up on
that nobody nobody who's hanging around
you is feeling like oh I feel low about
myself because of Alex and he doesn't
make me feel belong if you asked any of
those
people how does Alex make you feel it's
only going to be a list of positive
things and if say no no be honest be
honest there'll still only be positive
things so you don't have to take it get
off the deep end and it's great to take
responsibility and accountability and
all this stuff it's great yes it's your
fault and like you don't have to go all
the way into the dumpster and that now
all these people deserve better and I
suck right that that's the wrong don't
focus on how much you have sucked at
doing this focus on all these people
what they could be great at and pour
that into them because you're doing it
out of love for them to be great as
opposed to guilt of you not doing better
so you sitting there feeling sad that
you're not doing a good enough job is
the wrong energy to carry into going to
meet them yeah so
think huh say be like I'm so sorry I
failed you that's the wrong energy what
you talking about yeah yeah yeah yeah if
you're going to spend time getting
emotional think about how great these
people can be not how you failed them
over the past because you haven't you
haven't failed them you've been great if
you ask them you know who has been a top
20 people in your life for past year
who've helped you I'm sure you'd be on
most people's list so you're a net
positive for all these people people
great doesn't mean you're doing your
best by any shot you can still do way
better but how you do better is not
through guilt on yourself is through
seeing greatness in them and helping
them feel that so believe in them more
and pour that into them okay I'll pour
in all right there you go all right Alex
say all right good luck go do it believe
believe to watch me Mentor another
entrepreneur watch the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there if you're going to work on sales
techniques alone you're only going so
far unless you are just a complete Beast
that is so highly driven that you can
push through your own programs